This day have set upon a mighty endeavor.
souls will be shaken with the violences of war.
in this hour of great sacrifice.
we shall prevail.
get your head down and keep moving.
move move
we are all that separates the world from darkness
the enemy  is ruthless
we can not
we must not fail
duty first?
hey Perez!
Bumpy enough for ya?
i got you
hold on
how many casualties?
we have to executed the mission
get me fuck out of here
how many?
we had orders
get to cover!
Lieutenant! tell them what we're all about!
no mission too difficult...
no sacrifice too great.
Come on! On me!
welcome to the bloody first.
you're a long way from Texas, farm boy.
Pre-order now and get access to the  private beta.